law jamaat teaches in a special school
his pupils are deaf right now they're
learning how to sign the letter A
schools for children with disabilities
are not easy to find in Tanzania when
these pupils learn how to describe
Samaki or fish it is all thanks to the
dedication of their teacher neely onda I
started this program 14 years ago
without a classroom and without a
teacher I was teaching deaf and mentally
disabled children in a room which was
used for storage catacombic ammonia
costo yama is committed and raises money
for new classrooms he was the only one
of his ten siblings who attended
secondary school one of the reasons he
fights for better education
opportunities children with impairments
are particularly vulnerable in Tanzania
which is why lawyer Ahmad started his
NGO hoc right what when you Liam agua
nakabili wanna changarro to gamble in
bali people with disabilities are faced
with a variety of challenges yo Quanda
beyond a true cuando new combi but if we
start in the area of Education ninety
percent of children with disabilities in
Tanzania are still not sent to schools
how I envy huling often times they are
neglected and hidden from their own
family's lawyer ma pays Jessica un waka
to into a visit her husband left her
when the couple realized their son
Gideon was mentally handicapped their
relatives also abandoned them it was
only Gideon's grandmother who helped law
Ahmad has done a lot for her son Gideon
she says
sanna Mandela Coney there is a
tremendous change he was not always
himself but after he started going to
the school he slowly started to change
anabolic learning to become independent
is especially important but equally
important is the ability to develop
social skills among themselves and to
gain the confidence to move on after
leaving loya mots classroom one of the
girls already has great plans I would
like to continue with my education up to
the secondary school and on to
University Law Jamaat is diligently
pursuing his vision of a better life for
his protégées and doing his best to
overcome the many obstacles in his way
as news of his work spreads his
classrooms are growing today law Ahmad
is in charge of almost a hundred pupils
at his school in arusha